Can you successfully follow up one of the most
beloved comic book movies of all time? Is it
possible to make a dude with teeny wings on
his feet and little green shorts look cool?
The answer is that yes, you can — but not
without a few compromises along the way.
Warning: Major spoilers for Black
Panther: Wakanda Forever ahead.
Costume designer Ruth E. Carter — who
became the first Black woman ever to
win the Oscar in the category for her
work on the first "Black Panther" — has
really outdone herself this time with her
return in "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever."
The costumes in "Wakanda Forever" range from
college kid streetwear to high-tech diving
suits to ceremonial funeral garb and so much
more. Queen Ramonda's many royal ensembles are
standouts. In various shades of jewel tones, from
form-fitting to billowing, her gowns all still
share the same design motif thanks to similar
prints and coordinating jewelry. Nakia's bright
and casual clothes from her scenes as a Haitian
teacher suit the character's personality just as
much as her vibrant greenish War Dog armor. And
the incredible quality of Namor's movie-specific
design does much of the work of transforming
the character from a longtime comics oddball
into a mythical anti-hero god. The outfits
are all visually interesting yet believable,
and how they pull inspiration from real
culture — ancient and modern — is commendable.
"She really can make you, like, click
into place with the costumes she puts
you in. She's a storyteller first."
Usually, if the camera is going to linger
on a particular shot in an MCU film, it's
because of fight choreography or expensive CGI. In
"Wakanda Forever," the camera frequently lingers
on characters just looking awesome in their
clothes; Carter's creations are that breathtaking.
While none of the designs in
"Wakanda Forever" are misses,
the fleet of vehicles in the film is probably
the weakest element, conceptually. On their own,
all the modes of transportation range
from fine to pretty cool. For instance,
the aircraft that arrives to transport T'Challa's
vibranium coffin almost resembles the face of a
black panther when it's lit up and viewed from
below, which is an interesting visual touch.
But when it actually levitates the casket
up in its tractor beam during the funeral,
it completely takes viewers out of what's an
otherwise serious, somber moment. Meanwhile,
some of the other planes that are deployed to
evacuate citizens during the flooding of Wakanda
look vaguely and curiously like simpler versions
of Nova Corps starships from "The Guardians of
the Galaxy." Even the large Wakandan ship
that serves as the main battleground for
the film's final fight feels kind of boring
and unmemorable. "Wakanda Forever's" vehicles
feel Marvel-y...they're just not the sleekest
or most exciting that the MCU has to offer.
"Wakanda Forever'' confronts heavy and pressing
global issues head-on. The film can be read as a
metaphor for nuclear proliferation. The Wakandans
possess the world's most powerful resource,
and everyone else is in a race to catch up. In
the past, real civilizations like Nazi Germany
or the Soviet Union have been the antagonists
in Marvel films. This time, it's modern America,
France, and the rest of the United Nations. Being
outgunned by a small African country has exposed
the west's hypocrisy. New CIA director Valentina
Allegra de Fontaine openly admits she dreams about
the U.S. controlling Earth's vibranium supply, but
a large chunk of the international intelligence
community is willing to resort to some pretty
villainous tactics to get that sweet magic metal.
At a United Nations meeting, Queen Ramonda
dramatically announces that Wakanda has foiled
a plot to steal vibranium from one of their
secret research facilities by having the Dora
Milaje march the captive offenders before
their heads of state. She argues it's not
vibranium's power she fears, but what humans
would do with it. It's a bold move to call
out these nations this way, but it works with
the story "Wakanda Forever" is trying to tell.
The sequel is also interested in colonialism and
its effects on indigenous people. In a flashback,
we see that Spanish conquistadors brought
ruin to Namor's people. His anger at and
distrust of the surface world stems from
the fallout. Even the film's resolution
in which two superpowered beings agree to
put vengeance aside and de-escalate their
fight plays into the nuclear symbolism and the
real world, Cold War policy of Mutually Assured
Destruction. "Wakanda Forever's" politics aren't
left or right; they're clear-eyed and practical.
Dominique Thorne is a likable addition to
the MCU as Riri Williams, aka Ironheart,
but the plot that introduces her isn't as good
as the character herself or Thorne's performance.
It's entertaining and gives "Wakanda Forever" some
propulsion early on, but it's also underbaked.
"That can't be good."
Riri's vibranium detecting school project ends
up in the hands of covert US operatives who are
using it to find heretofore unknown
quantities of vibranium from a sea
bed in the Atlantic Ocean. This interference
threatens Namor and his people's way of life,
and kicks off the conflict between
Namor and Wakanda. Namor wants to
kill the scientist who made the machine,
while Shuri is determined to protect Riri.
Unfortunately, Riri's actual involvement in
the story doesn't amount to much. There's a
fun moment early on where she helps Shuri and
Okoye escape the local police with the help of
her homemade Ironheart suit, but after that she's
little more than a plot football. Hardly anything
she does from this point forward affects the
events of the film. Her more polished Ironheart
armor helps Shuri's plan to trap Namor in the
final battle, but her character's motivations
aren't much more than "don't die, help Wakanda."
The movie keeps trying to tell us that she'll be
important with a few hints of her backstory,
but we rarely see that importance take shape.
Like America Chavez in "Doctor Strange and the
Multiverse of Madness," Riri is an exciting new
character with tons of potential who's
reduced mostly to a human MacGuffin.
One of the smartest decisions Ryan Coogler
and company made was swapping Marvel Comics'
Atlantis for the mythical Mesoamerican city
of Talokan — a fictionalization of Tlālōcān,
one of the Aztec afterlives. Of course, the
decision was more or less made for them since
Warner Bros. beat Marvel to the screen with
Aquaman. Nevermind that Namor came first in
the comics — Aquaman has always been the
better known half-blood king of Atlantis.
"Wakanda Forever" changed
that bit of Namor's backstory,
and it works wonderfully. In the film version,
his origin story has everything to do with a
vibranium meteorite and Spanish conquistadors.
Rooting Namor in Aztec and Mayan history and
culture is a vast improvement on an
already intriguing comics character,
and the Talokan that the filmmakers
created for him rivals Wakanda.
Born with prolonged life and the ability
to breathe air and water, as well as the
gift of flight because of the wings on his
feet, Namor is given the title K'uk'ulkan or
Feathered Serpent God, a supernatural entity
pulled from Mesoamerican religion. As a boy,
he becomes a legend to his people when he
uses his power to fight back against Spanish
colonizers. Since the MCU has been interested in
geopolitical issues and gods lately, this updated
version of Namor and his home of Talokan fits
right into the cinematic universe's trajectory.
Okoye became one of the breakout characters in
"Black Panther" for good reason. The leader of
the Dora Milaje was as stoic and tough as anyone
in the first film, save for T'Challa himself. Her
storyline saw her wrestle with the question of
what to do when Killmonger assumed the throne.
Though Danai Gurira is every bit as captivating
in "Wakanda Forever," the film doesn't do her
justice. She gets a stunning entrance when the
Dora Milaje infiltrate the French operatives
planning to steal and study vibranium, but for
much of the second half of the movie, she's MIA.
When Shuri and Riri are captured, Ramonda blames
Okoye and dismisses her from duty. Devastated,
one of the best characters and best actors
in the film is sidelined. In a movie with
way too many characters to fully develop,
it's a shame that one of the franchise's
best doesn't get enough screen time
to continue her own fascinating story.
In the comics, Namor and Black Panther have
a real love-hate relationship. Sometimes they
align themselves and their kingdoms
with each other for a common cause,
and they are both superhuman rulers of super
secret societies. But more often than not,
they're at each other's throats.
With "Wakanda Forever," somebody
other than T'Challa had to put on the Black
Panther's mask — and face off against Namor.
Though Chadwick Boseman and Tenoch Huerta
would've been phenomenal scene partners,
Huerta and Letitia Wright's Shuri have a totally
different chemistry that takes Namor and the
Black Panther's love-hate relationship
to another level. In this adaptation,
there's actually some romantic tension between
the mutant god king and the scientist princess.
It's never made explicit except for that pretty
high-value gift of his beloved mother's bracelet.
When Namor offers to take Shuri to Talokan and
wistfully confides in her that she's the first
surface human ever to have seen their
world, it's not hard to imagine them as
allies — and maybe something more. There's
a tragic irony to the idea that these two
understand each other but are destined to
become enemies, for a time at least. When
Ramonda orders Nakia to invade his home and
she kills some of his people to rescue Shuri,
he retaliates by flooding Wakanda and indirectly
killing many citizens, including Ramonda herself.
Even their final showdown is charged with
shared emotion; they're both isolated, angry,
and — as Namor's name means in this take on the
character — without love. But if only broken
people can be great leaders, there are big things
ahead for Namor and Shuri, together or not.
"Both nations want the same thing, which
is to preserve and to protect their people,
but they're willing to go
about it in different ways."
When the MCU first took us to Wakanda,
viewers got to meet a plethora of new
characters including more people of color
and more women than the franchise had ever
seen before. In addition to T'Challa,
his supporting cast of all had unique,
fleshed-out personalities of their own. "Wakanda
Forever" advertised that audiences would become
acquainted with a second superpowered
civilization. The trailers and casting
news indicated that Attuma and Namora — two
important characters from the comics — would
be living and fighting alongside Namor, just
as Okoye and M'Baku did in "Black Panther."
In the comics, Attuma is a barbarian-like
Atlantean who believes that he ought to rule
instead of Namor. And throughout her comics
history, Namora has been everything from
Namor's implied lover to his cousin to a clone.
Even with the change from Atlantis to Talokan,
there's enough backstory to have made Attuma
and Namora more unique characters. Instead,
one of "Wakanda Forever's" weak spots is the
regrettable underdevelopment of its Talokanil
supporting cast. They're deployed — much
like "Infinity War's" Ebony Maw and Proxima
Midnight — like a henchman and henchwoman
who are little more than bodies in the way
until it's time for the main characters
to fight Namor. We get little more than
a hint that Namora is dissatisfied with Namor
and Shuri's peaceful resolution near the end.
It's become a refrain that most Marvel movies
are great…until the final act devolves into
a CGI soup, the main ingredients of which
are faceless hordes, Kaiju-like monsters,
and of course, sky beams and portals. Most of the
criticism of the first "Black Panther," in fact,
came for its lackluster last-act digital
effects. It seems the filmmakers have
learned from their mistakes and
from worn-out MCU tropes. The final
battle in "Wakanda Forever" is one of Marvel
Studios' shorter and smaller-scale scuffles,
but in terms of relevance to the plot and
visual style, it's a breath of fresh air.
Shuri finally steps into a leadership role as
the Black Panther, literally standing as the
vanguard of her troops atop a massive military
vessel. They're planning to lure Namor to them so
they can trap him in a retrofitted aircraft that
will dry him out and deplete his powers. Just as
Namor is his people's god of the air, land, and
sea, this climactic conflict unfolds in the sky,
sand, and on the Atlantic. Riri Williams
gleefully buzzes through the clouds in her
tricked-out Ironheart suit. Shuri crash-lands
on the shore, and the Black Panther and the
Feathered Serpent God slash at each other
acrobatically in the sand and flames. The
Dora Milaje use cables to take on the Talokanil
in an impressively choreographed vertical assault,
while the Jabari defend the deck. It's
perfect for the story "Wakanda Forever"
is trying to tell, which is about how war
is rarely in a nation's best interest.
This might sound like a backhanded compliment,
but the MCU's Namor looks way cooler than anyone
who's familiar with the comics probably
expected. In his earliest illustrated form,
Namor looks like a turn-of-the-century muscle
man in a belted speedo. And then there's the
matter of those pointy elf ears and those
little angelic wings that grow out of his
feet. Even after Namor got an emo makeover
in the 2000s, writers and artists still had
to contend with those quirks, as did Ryan
Coogler in "Wakanda Forever." As per usual,
the writer-director was up to the task.
Namor is one of the highlights of the movie.
"My enemies call me Namor."
In part, that's thanks to the casting of Tenoch
Huerta and his performance, which ranges from
endearing to frightening. And in part, that's
thanks to the character's new backstory and
status as an indigenous Mexican god-king. Namor
still has his skimpy green shorts, but the costume
has been redesigned with native iconography
and materials. Somehow, even the image of the
mutant hovering in place — his tiny foot-wings
flapping fast — isn't ridiculous. All of this is
an enormous accomplishment, considering how often
Namor looks silly in comic books and how serious
"Wakanda Forever" is for most of its runtime. The
only moments in which it's hard to take the movie
and its anti-hero seriously come when the mutant
leaps and bounds through set pieces like Legolas
doing parkour, or when he uses his winged feet to
dash across the sky, not unlike a hummingbird. CGI
has come a long way, but it still can't make
superhuman feats like that look very natural.